but i i think it's pretty incredible
that you know you come up for a three
guest star spot or whatever and then all
of a sudden you're working 12 years on a
show
were you i mean you must have been
really good you must have just fit right
the [ __ ] in
for them to make you a regular that
quick i well they didn't make me a
regular that quick it it was by degrees
they we kept adding three more episodes
three more episodes and then finally
they were like all right it looks like
we're stuck with you um but i didn't fit
in i don't think i think it was an
interesting um mix where i was actually
i was
somehow
i was a foil uh to
sam and dean's characters and and i was
different enough that it kind of
filled out the cast a little bit in a
way
um that if i when i when i first uh got
on set i hadn't really watched the show
i was like a kind of lazy guest star
actor i was like i don't know nobody
watches me that's what i want to do who
cares i got i don't know i'll be gone
and i'll be gone before anyone even
knows that i was here
and so uh i i knew that i was gonna be
playing an angel
and so i kind of showed up with this
very ethereal other earth you know
otherworldly quality and you added the
voice and i had the voice you know the
deep
voice for various reasons because i
thought that was going to be cool it
turned out it was a pain in the ass for
a long time but i um
i we did the first take and uh the
producer who was also the director the
executive producer director kim manners
uh came up to me and he said uh
can you try to do that again but not not
so spooky
and i was just like up i was the wrong
tone for the show altogether because all
of the characters that played demons or
witches or whatever they just came
across as real humans in the show at
that point and i was playing something
that was like spook spooky and
otherworldly because i didn't hadn't
watched the show
um but ultimately as that character got
tweaked and honed uh i i was a fish out
of water i didn't quite fit in but it
was actually in a weird way kind of what
the show needed at that point
um
and
and i think you know obviously it worked
to an extent because yeah they kept me
there for you know i watched outtakes i
just saw these outtakes and it just
seems like the whole time
jensen and jared are [ __ ] with you
that that is a fair characterization of
my experience i mean it's non-stop yeah
it's a it's abuse it's abuse because
then you have a lot i mean you always
had to say a bunch of
you had a lot of lines but i had plenty
of lines yeah plenty of lines and they
would uh incessantly
[ __ ] with me
and you're trying to remember these
lines and they're [ __ ] or trying to
even just say them um yes um it was
it was maddening at times but it was
also
um i think
demonstrative of the fact that we had a
lot of fun on set like we i i think it
it is probably
north of a million dollars in overtime
that warner brothers had to pay
for because of us walking around on set
over the years yeah but without
hyperbole i think that's probably is it
safe to say i mean like you probably
love these guys like brothers i mean but
you all three are extremely close
yeah it is you know it's funny i think
that um one of the one of the
interesting things about the
supernatural fandom is that they're all
of these factions like there are people
who consider themselves
sam fans and dean fans and jared fans
and misha fans and a lot of times they
butt heads there are you know
small but vocal minorities of these of
the fandom that like the jared fans who
hate the misha fans or hate that i came
on the show at all and you know and you
have people that hate you yes and
and i but i think that they're also
small but vocal groups that think that
we actors don't get along or that you
know there's some feud going on between
me and jared or jared and jensen or
whatever and the fact of the matter is
we get along great and when we you know
hang up or end phone calls with one
another we always say love you brother
can't wait to see you i mean we're like
we really love and care for each other
um but there's this whole narrative
maybe it's maybe it's the sorry i keep
banging
maybe it's the fans um trying to
find a way to cultivate some additional
drama uh now that but there really isn't
any drama to be said no you never had a
day where you're like oh my god [ __ ] off
oh no no we've all we are like